what is the multi-annual financial
framework often refer to as MFF it may
sound complicated but it is simply the
--use long term budget it stretches over
several years and funds complex programs
such as Erasmus and Galileo the MFF
determines the amounts that match the
--use priorities this in turn ensures
stability the MFF also sets limits on
how much the European Union will spend
and in which areas the main EU
institutions all work to shape the MFF
EU leaders who meet in the European
Council to provide political guidance
and the Commission the council in the
parliament that complete the process how
does the process work the Commission
makes the initial proposal then it's up
to the council which has a central role
it ensures all EU countries are part of
the agreement next the Parliament is
asked to give its consent once it does
so the council adopts the MFF through a
unanimous vote find out all you need to
know about the MFF and much more on
Concilium 0 / tu
[Music]